vous présenter quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup c'est pourri ce qui est avec
nous boris à ce qu'apple boris au site
ont presque
c'est boris aux gitans de notre ami
qu'on aime énormément boris mon chéri on
rappelle au rappel le principe on va
pouvoir gagner un billet pour la laponie
en grimpant cette échelle et en allant
chercher le billet qui est en haut ça
veut dire si vous êtes six à avoir le
billet vous êtes si près du game rideau
d'une guerre aux la merci des
liquidations total par contre si on a
aucun qui le fait c'est terminé enfin il
y aura pas de billets aujourd'hui rideau
terminé merci pour l'instant il n'y en a
qu'un et par la police et vincent cassel
étant donné que géraldine mady a une
douleur aux lombaires également au
louvre j'aurais peut être moi mais
benjamin castaldi s'est proposé merci
benjamin voilà et ouais elle à l aine
douleurs aux lombaires et on embrasse
d'ailleurs voilà christophe les séries
ce boris est ce que tu peux nous faire
une petite démonstration
on voulait montrer que c'est hyper
simple d'un bon oui j'ai un bon boris
soit tu sais toi tu le fais souvent
ouverts c'est la première fois que tu le
veuilles ou non ça fait plusieurs années
j'avais attrapé ou d'accord on va dire
que c'est la première fois que je fais
on va la refaire
bon il s'apprend a battu le fait oui
c'est le bonheur pas d'humoristes
allez c'est parti boris contre nogaro tu
fais basile boli
regardez c'est rsa il va aller chercher
le billet vous connaissez voilà il ya
une échelle voilà voilà
voilà pour un bon mot bravo mot est bon
voilà boris excellent je suis plus ce
n'est pas si évident alors qu'yb ou par
tel comeback
voilà cauris on y va tu ne donne aucun
conseil mais c'est trop beau montrer que
c'est assez simple voilà normalement il
n'y a pas de souci on va démarrer où il
peut nous montrer chef
alors moi j'ai boris a montré je rentre
rappel aucun souci on va démarrer pas
aller au raz de marée par make things
est derrière elle et maxime
on y va c'est participe jamais
d'apprendre billets ses gardiens a dit
moshe bases émotionnelles et aller à les
remercier
[Musique]
marjorie chadway talon droit à l'eau
matin c'est celui qui tirait la mauricie
peux me remettre mon chéri bon ici que
tu peux rappeler les règles
c'était un landreau en équilibre monte à
l'endroit en équipe aux montées comme
une échelle voilà de pas mal sinon moi
je vais arriver là je vais le prendre
comme ça donc mon arrivée à londres on
équilibre aux dépens de ne pas sauter ne
pas couvrir mon pc comme une échelle
normal et si comme ils se nomment et si
tu sens que tu tombes
je fais ce qu'on me l'enlève
si maxime merci match aller alors on y
va avec
on va aller delphine attention les
chaussures fifi relaté on l'était
chaussettes s'est passé de la terre ce
vieux bénisse les pieds elle a développé
oui sans rigoler franchement on
mangerait dessus allez là des bobines
reste un peu plus longtemps
c'est le sort que delphine pack très
longue sur l'échelle à les défis elle
finit 7e rappelle que tu fais parti de
fort boyard
allez vas-y dauphine
samadet c'est là ma chérie ça va ma
chérie ouais ouais ça va d'un film là je
suis en mode de la faune ou alors pour
l'instant c'est pas bon pour delphine
attention filet on va bernard montiel
allez les verts et oui pense que c'est
un billet pour 45 minutes faciale ça le
stimule à la faune africaine repose
maurice
du coup voilà merci à l'est il s'est
fait aussi à l'épaule va on y va avec
eux je valais daniel tu envie de faire
daniel non allez daniel vas-y on
rappelle ivan basso ita daniele moro
n'aura pas qu'elle en a monté des
échelles de vous lire je suis la seule
sauvages images choc et daniel ne prend
pas de risque et daniel qui le prend pas
de risque si tu sens que c'est pas bon
daniel jeu tutu base
ok daniel facile à dire vas-y daniel
daniel masi nantis qui donnera à l'état
ferait pas peur à la peur daniel a peur
et je comprends ma chérie je comprends
vachiery à l'atp en très sportive et à
qui les traite à 1 alors est il ajouté
dans le maire isabelle morini-bosc elle
regarde
ericsson 4 on dirait qu'à une case avec
des tigres mon frère cadet harry
franchement mal jean michel baylet allez
vas-y il a perdu son billet pour la la
peine d'y aller pour toi un agent bien
lé guen c'est pas évident je reviens
aujourd'hui c'est bon là ça part bien
ça partait bien aller merci jean michaud
rue c'est horrible abbas impossible son
attention attention ne va pas de casser
et va pas de casser la binette ce qu'ils
n'ont pas fait je les reconnais yake
libé devaient dia gilbert grellet ce que
tu veux essayer
bah oui bien sûr alors attention tu dois
rester droit mon chéri mois bon il sait
ce que tu peux redonne un conseil si tu
peux fait contrepoids votre corps fait
contrepoids et votre qu avec votre corps
c'est à dire avec qui avec votre corps
amazing mois montre moi parce que tu
peux lui montrez vous inversez toujours
le la position des membres du corps des
gens aimeraient bien séquanien exact à
un pied gauche à trois arrêts bazooka lé
basket souvent hyper bien merci cyril
alors salut qu à peine mieux avec maxime
qui était pas si mal mais non mais
franchement les mecs jouent combat pro
vie arrive mais je vais prendre la boj
peu importe qui osent a qu'à regarder
c'est pas moi papa maury trava saïd bien
ça il va dit est ce que tu peux nous
montrer ça y est tu sûr qu'il va arriver
à le faire renora 10 à yves mazille
montre leur que tout roule arrive à le
faire je m'en bas y'a que vous
la bande et je suis certain qu'ils
soient là gentiment bon à la versys
narcisse hays douala et ben voila voila
merci saïd merci cei à table at on
attendu ait said merci frère ou c'est
une bombe
voilà c'est pas que c'est pas compliqué
bravo c'est vers 6 heures avant alors
attention
il manque allait il nous reste benjamin
castaldi et kelly et maxime kenny il
veut il jouer une dernière chance allez
on y va avec benjamin castaldi
halleguen tu y joues pour géraldine à
les séparer
comme j'aime pas ça comme j'aime et
wyatte à cinq femmes en moi
ne confondez pas les verts dû aller voir
c'était dégueulasse et on va faire
isabey et après on finira par kelly et
maxime torrent une dernière chance
comment c'est tout
non mais vous croyez pas que non mais
les chéris http laponie farguettes sur
quelqu'un ça fait quoi toi ça c'est pas
toi je suis désolé c'est pas toi bonjour
qu'est ce que tu veux essayer
oui mais ce cas à l'évasion dans les
vasières et c'est parce que je me vois
bien que je pense qu'elle 99% à
l'espagne pilote à l'édition padie chéri
est passé bien là rien qui exposerait et
posco ou un cdi
pas grave et a été on peut le dire a
[Applaudissements]
indiqué li
je connais des chaussures quand même
merci à bâle à elle a perdu 50 centimes
ça va aller kelly a livré comme ça le
tennis est pas mal par son contrepoids
donc à main bien pied droit voilà
comment mais l'histoire est franchement
à logements est ton point bon job au
château à gauche c'est bien
c'était pas mal tu veux réveiller
allez vas-y vite les dernières chances
harper ni son regard narines avec bah
oui oui on va montrer d'eux après gagner
merci à elle s'est battue allez maxime
rigaud maxime j'ai beaucoup réfléchi je
t'épouse humour et boquita règle la
question en pet positive la croix
[Applaudissements]
et cela n'importe quoi et n'importe quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
d'autant qu'il est
[Musique]